は）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと
は）みなさん　UNO　やったことありますか？
は）やったことありますか？
は） やったことありますか？
は）全員やったことあるんですけども
は)進めていくんですけども
は）ちょっと今ここに実物があるんですけどもぉ
は）最初プレイヤーは1人7枚ずつカードをもって
は）ゲームが進んでいきます。（丸読み）
パサ（紙の音）
は）少ねぇぇぇぇぇぇ！！！！！！！！
一同）ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は）いや7枚だと早いじゃないですか勝負が　早ない？
の）運がいい人は早いですよね確かに
は）いやいや
は）早いんだよ！ｗｗｗｗ
は）早いと思ってたので
は）今回UNOを14箱準備したので
は）14X112で1500枚ぐらい（1708枚）UNOがあるので
は）今回1人手札100でUNOやっていこうと思います
は）これもうひょっとしたら
は）って感じなので
は）ちょっと今回この4人で
は）UNOを手札100枚でやっていこうと思います！
は）いくぞ！！
は）おぉぉぉぉぉぉ
は）えぇぇぇ⤵
はいというわけで約1500枚(1708枚)の
UNOのカードがこちらに出ました
うおぉぉぉ　パチパチ（拍手 ）素晴らしい
混ざらない　ハハハ(笑い声)
(しばらくおまちください)
ただあの、わからないのが
地域によってなんですけど
1枚しか出せないところと　たくさん出せるとかあったじゃん
同じ数字とか　同じ…
あれどうだった
うちは1枚しか出せなかった
2が出てたら自分は1枚しか出せない
2を何枚持ってても1枚しか出せなかった　俺の家は
おれの村では…
wwwwwww
俺の村では　一緒に出せました
あ～
わしのむらでも一緒に出せましたよ
わしの県では...出せました
出せることにしよっか
じゃあ同じ数字とかあったら出していくから
ドロー２　3枚
ばしって出したら
次の人はドロー６になる
よろしくお願いします!
よろしくお願いします
じゃまずは、みなさん”100”枚
とっていきます
1...
2...
97...
98...
99...
100～～
ﾊｱ...ﾊｱ...
よし、
あ、たしかにwwwww
いやこれは強いわ
(pon)
最初はグー
じゃんけんホイ
あいこでしょ (1)
あいこでしょ(2)
あいこでしょ(3)
あいこでしょ(4)
あいこでしょ(5)
1番！
さいしょはグー
じゃんけんほい！
時計回りのほうがいいか...
じゃあ　いきます
じゃ行きます
二枚
じゃ俺三枚
スキップ　スキップ
fuffuffuffu
はい
(でーーん)
おおおおお
8！
さすがに厳しいと思うよ
12はやばい
14 16 18
参りました
wwww
26枚！？
みなさんこのぬるい展開に
あきあきしてきた頃だと思います
(でーーん)
Draw Two
おーーー
six
eight
twelve
14(日本語で)
持ってる
おーーー
では参る
20!
24でござる
ﾊｱ､ﾊｱ､
うう～～う　五十二
WWWWW
( ﾟДﾟ)
もう持ってなかったの
SOREHAHETA
51.52
88888(パチパチパチパチ)
(フェードアウト)
じゃ、行こうか